[Music]
from the book of saw
[Music]
um
get your [ __ ] hands in the air
i ain't gonna say it again [ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh
[Applause]
hello detective bosworth i want to play
a game
the three train is arriving in two
minutes it is up to you to decide if
this will be your final stop
you have taken the witness stand many
times and reloaded innocent people with
your lies
putting them away in jail today
it is you who will be railroaded you
have one chance to live
tear from your mouth the tongue that has
so often been used to light and to
deceive
take a leap of faith and you will live
only your weight
will rip away your mind tongue and save
you live or die
make your choice
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
this package just came in
[Music]
get everybody out here
play me
hello detective banks do you know where
your officers are
jigsaw well i thought that jigsaw killer
was dead
he is
find them their hours not days how can i
catch this guy if there's nobody on the
bus
i can fuss you can't do this alone
whoever did this has another motive
something personal
was the last time you saw your father
[Music]
to get us out of the precinct
i need everyone on this case
it could be anywhere he could be anyone
we're gonna tear this city apart
[Music]
hello detective banks when was the last
time
you saw your father
[Music]
you